(gentle music)
- [Zoe] Thousands of people
come into the United States
each day with nothing.
Some of them become
day laborers and end up
in detention centers when
detained by authorities.
But outside these federal prisons,
a band called Los Jornaleros del Norte
sends a message of hope.
(speaking in foreign language)
(singing in foreign language)
(gentle music)
- I'm Zoe Saldana from BESE,
and I'm teaming up with Great
Big Story to shine a light
on American Latinx excellence
around the country.
(soft music)
(speaking in foreign language)
(lively Mexican music)
- [Zoe] The band plays
all over the country,
but they have a special connection
to one place in particular:
(singing in foreign language)
the detention center in
downtown Los Angeles.
It primarily houses undocumented workers
who have been arrested
and face deportation.
(singing in foreign language)
In 2010, the band marched in front
of the gigantic building,
singing songs of protest
to raise awareness for
the unfair deportation
of the people waiting inside.
The band continues to do
these concerts to this day
but will never forget
that first experience.
(speaking in foreign language)
(gentle music)
(gentle electronic music)